the booze you make bad decisions and i
you so so your drink so at this point
when you start drinking
are you drinking heavy yes yeah i had a
problem you did yeah i mean i'm hungover
now
yeah uh i got mugged in new york a bunch
of times just because i was so
drunk that it was like you could just
take the wall out of my pocket i didn't
know what was going on
and i lived in brooklyn like way out i
got mugged a bunch
but uh yeah so i you know i was boozing
it up in cleveland
you know not bragging and um
i met this gal this is years ago years
ago and i remember thinking like
all right i'm gonna be a good guy here
and try to do the right thing we don't
have a condom
so we can't bang you know i'm trying to
be a little more responsible
and we're in my hotel room and we're
both kind of uh what do we do in
cleveland
everything closes it's all done so i was
like
i got an idea because we're both wanting
to do something i go what if i
put it in the keister we won't need a
condom for that you can't get pregnant
in the ass not that i've heard i know of
if that were the case and gays would be
having babies all day long but uh
so that but also you're you're what
you're not considering is still the std
i know
i didn't even think about it i was like
what what's just about a baby's all
you're thinking about
yeah because what std lives in the end
yeah all of them
especially aids the big the big hiv
so all of them live in the [ __ ] in my
mind this was the responsible thing to
do
so uh she was like all right great so we
went to town
and i remember thinking like all right
you got to pee after that's how you
flush everything
yeah really trying to be responsible and
and whatever and uh
we i don't have you ever had an std no
it hits you about two weeks it's usually
like 13 14 days
that's how long it takes to really
notice it and i remember the next day
i was like god damn what i got the next
day yeah i was like
so i was like this in my head i was like
this is a really bad one
you know if it hit that early yeah
that's what my dumb brain thought like
this is a really
serious std so immediately i went aids
you go right to the top and then there's
a lot of gay or anal aids you know but
this was a one-night stand correct
yes yeah ain't an anal first date
yeah anal that's cleveland one night's
day yeah
that's a wednesday it's the browns
cleveland browns baby that was the
mascot
wow so uh yeah i i i had to do the
horrible thing
we all hate to do you text the girl the
next day go hey i hate to do this but
do you have anything i should know about
you know and uh she was like oh my god
of course not geez i could yes and it's
just super awkward i'm like all right i
just feel weird and something's up i'm
just checking no
you know no no judgment and she's like
no no [ __ ] you whatever
and i was like all right and then you
know the next couple days it's like god
damn
i am [ __ ] i have something bad what's
happening just uh
aching like and you're in your dick in
there in it
in it does it burn when you pee gotta
burn when you pee
and you have you ejaculated again
yourself you masturbate
since i want to know if it hurt when
that came out no i was too worried about
it i didn't want to [ __ ] with it
yeah so i was peeing it didn't burn you
the burn is the big
tell yeah that's the that's the go-to so
this was a no burn
and an ache and a pain and a sting so
i'm like i don't know what it is
so i thought it was some high level but
it's only in your dick
yes it's not radiating in anywhere else
no radiation
and uh i i'm losing it so i go to the
hospital
in like the what do you call the clinic
the one hour clinic
and i do a whole test i go you're clean
and i go well i got some something's up
and they're like ah it's probably in
your head
and they're like take some antibiotics
yeah
it's my [ __ ] so i was like all right
so i'm taking it and you know nothing's
working
so i know this doctor guy so i just
called him and it just kind of like
unloaded on him and he goes
huh i bet you got [ __ ] in your dick
that's not the doctors that's what the
doctor is i just use the word ejaculate
and this guy says you have [ __ ] in your
dick
yeah and i was like i don't know i don't
know about that you know
everything looked fine it's a small hole
really
and your dick so you're like ah that
can't be it that can't be it
and he goes take these pills and these
pills are designed to go into your body
into your dick and kill the [ __ ] somehow
they like dissolve it but he goes these
are strong because they have to be super
strong to go into your
body yeah all the way up in your dick
yeah
so he's like whatever you do like you
take these pills
have a free day don't do a show don't
drive don't take a flight or whatever
and i was like ah
be fine so i wanted to really kill what
was in me so i just took them all
you know he's supposed to take him like
one a day for three days kind of thing
and i took all three jesus christ and
he's telling you one of these is gonna
[ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly so i took all three and i
was like i'm fine who cares cause i and
also i really wanted to kill it
i really wanted it to work like what on
a scale of one to ten what pain level
are you at on a daily basis
would you legit say it was pretty bad i
mean it was it was a five but it's still
but it's in your dick yes that's a ten
that's your ten your brain is going
quick could it be this could be that
so it's a mental ten but probably a pain
fair enough
all right so i take the pills and he
goes make sure you eat
and i was like yeah yeah yeah yeah i
hadn't eaten it was like noon and i
hadn't eaten that day and i just
popped and they were big they were like
big horse pills and i
gulped them down and uh you know 10
minutes walk by or went by
and i just felt like and i started
feeling weak like i could barely get off
the couch
and i said i better go eat so i remember
i was in new york walking down sixth
avenue trying to get to a pizza place
and i went to the pizza and i'm just
like and i had to sit down
and i had to sit down and order from the
chair and be like can i get two slices
and i fell asleep in the chair like they
knocked me out so the guy like the
little
italian guy is like hey what the [ __ ]
are you doing you junkie you piece of
[ __ ] get out of here
[Laughter]
covered in [ __ ] here and uh so
i got i scarfed down the slices and i
felt better but
like the whole day i was like whoa i was
all wonky i had to do shows and
everything
and it was bad but it worked it did
killed it how fast just a couple days a
couple days
next day i think i felt better than two
days later i felt 100
fine see i mean ass [ __ ] goes back so
if there's a pill
yeah [ __ ] out of your dick yeah ass
[ __ ] goes back for
centuries that's the good the romans
yeah way back the greeks
the greeks the greeks that's what that
meant yeah yeah i'm sure the romans
asked [ __ ] the law too
oh yeah they invented